bonjour à toutes et à tous aujourd'hui
[Musique]
j'ai été invité il est extrêmement
difficile à détricoter je suis pas un
polémiste c'est ça je suis pas rodé à
l'exercice de la communication
médiatique
je suis pianiste
je suis engagé sur la cause de l'autisme
notamment invisible voilà non mais tu as
raison William c'est bien que tu le
dises parce que là il y a plein de gens
moi j'ai vu ils sont tombés dessus sur
les réseaux tout ça lui William il est
pas là dedans William il est il voulait
parler de sa cause de l'autisme il s'est
dit en ayant pépédia il va y avoir plus
de résonance c'est tout voilà sur Sako
c'est ça en fait ce que je suis venu
dire c'est que ce serait bien qui est
davantage de considération pour les
artistes en situation de handicap parce
qu'on en parle jamais ce sont des
artistes qui ont beaucoup de choses à
transmettre
ce serait bien d'ailleurs quand on fasse
un film documentaire sur eux sur ces
artistes handicapés qui souffrent de
leur exclusion et on se moque d'eux il y
en a qui sont maltraités méprisés abusés
c'est une réalité dont on parle pas
c'est vous qui avez contacté comme un
tableau parce que soit vous vouliez le
dire aussi voilà il dit que c'est pas
possible aussi que un mec voilà qui qui
se bat pour une cause qui est noble
après voilà il a invité PPDA justement
il s'est dit quoi il s'est dit ça va
avoir plus de résonance et une claquette
de résidence va être plus importante et
au moins on va parler de ma cause et et
William voilà il a pas fait pour voilà
il a fait juste pour sa cause et
derrière il y en a plein qui lui tombe
dessus donc c'est c'est quoi des réseaux
qui sont sur les réseaux on ne sait
quand on ne voit pas et quand on ne sait
pas votre handicap qui est un handicap
il faut en parler qui est handicap
invisible on tombe sur une interview
d'un jeune homme qui interview quelqu'un
qui est accusé d'agression sexuelle et
de viol et vous démarrez votre interview
sur à parfois le romantisme vous vous le
faites passer enfin en tout cas il se
présente comme une personne extrêmement
sympathique empathique que qui est
atteint effectivement de temps en temps
de dépression et que donc cette
sensibilité fait avoir un rapport aux
autres qui est particulièrement délicat
et quand on sait qu'il est enfin en tout
cas qui les femmes ont raconté il y a
évidemment ce télescope et donc on ne
sait pas qui vous êtes vous et c'est
pour ça que vous qu'on vous tombe de ce
que les gens vous tombent dessus et bien
qu'il soit là
exactement William pourquoi vous l'avez
choisi lui ouais comment ça c'est fait
comment vous avez
c'est vous qui l'avez contacté
en fait je suis venu parler d'une
réalité dont on parle pas et je vais
vous faire un peu c'est ce tabou dont je
suis venu parler du manque de
représentativité de l'autisme dans les
médias et surtout dans la culture
d'accord et je sais je sais pas comment
vous allez le prendre mais c'est plutôt
sur ce sujet là que je suis venu parler
je sais que vous avez des impératifs
d'audience mais je pense que parler
d'autisme dans la culture et des médias
bien sûr tu constructif socialement que
de parler de de plus
je comprends tout à fait raison après
moi je veux pas vous prendre vous pouvez
même poser la question à vos abonnés sur
Twitter si vous préférez entendre parler
d'autisme je pense qu'effectivement ça
peut être plus constructif socialement
que de parler de parler Twitter oui on a
peur que vous soyez baissé par les
Twitter et tout ça voilà moi je pense
c'est à ça c'est William qui nous a
contacté à la production ce soir pour
parler ça et en même temps pour voilà et
courageuse bien sûr venir William comme
ça et je vais te dire c'est toi
contextualisme voilà vous avez raison
mais j'aurais voulu savoir quand même si
vous lui avez dit à PPDA est-ce qu'on
peut se poser toutes les que je peux
vous poser toutes les questions de
remblai il vous a dit genre on parle pas
de mes affaires etc moi la question que
je me pose c'est qui s'intéresse au
handicap dans la culture et les médias
et jusqu'où faut-il aller pour pouvoir
en parler sur un plateau de télévision
mais parce que je crois que c'est c'est
là c'est là où je suis c'est extrêmement
délicat de faire entendre cette cause là
quand c'est pas dans des situations qui
font le buzz quand c'est pas le mois de
l'autisme
mais c'est très important j'étais
content que tu viennes parce que c'est
surtout sur ça on va appuyer parce que
il y en a plein qui sont tombés dessus
je te dis parce que tu as reçu mes PDF
est-ce que tu voulais c'était une caisse
de résonance et dire dans les médias les
outils sont pas du tout représentés
parce que il est là ce soir je vous dis
par contre il y a pas un article qui dit
que chez représenté chez nous hier on
avait euh
Dylan
on a je te rappelle que tous les
vendredis on fait une émission qui
s'appelle CPMP ouvert à tous on a une
personne en situation de handicap on est
les seuls et les les Sofia mais on fait
pas de ça ce qui est très important
pardon c'est que du coup les gens vont
voir ce soir à la fois combien William
est sincères
parce que sinon si on n'avait pas su il
se ferait massacrer sur les réseaux il
est fragile et il fallait pas faire un
coup médiatique
veut juste parler de sa cause donc vas-y
mon William donc l'insulte pas
merci beaucoup moi effectivement ce que
je trouve extrêmement regrettable c'est
que les artistes en situation de
vulnérabilité de handicap de handicap
invisible en particulier ceux qui sont
porteurs d'autisme d'autisme asperger
comme on dit parfois comme moi l'autisme
de haut niveau invisible sont déficient
intellectuel on les voit jamais ils ont
pas accès verbalement à des codes qui
pourraient leur permettre d'entrer en
contact avec des personnes qui sont
faussement ouvertes parfois ces médias
là c'est parfois des choses à double
tranchant on sait pas comment leur
adresser la parole moi j'ai essayé de
solliciter des personnes et en soi je
vous aime bien parce que vous laissez la
parole à des personnes alors que dans
des grands médias je les mets au défi à
compter les articles qu'ils ont fait je
sais pas depuis deux ans merci on parle
d'autisme même des médias qui se disent
respectables qui prennent des grands
airs parfois de devenir
il ne parle pas de ça et ça c'est je
trouve que c'est c'est scandaleux on
peut dire aussi que les artistes avaient
autisme avec handicap parfois on abuse
d'eux ils sont pas suffisamment
considérés on va dire ah bah tiens tu es
déjà ta papillon sur et en plus par
dessus le marché tu as handicap bon
parfois c'est dit de façon plus on va
pas on va pas les employer on va pas
leur trouver des agents on trouve qu'ils
sont pas suffisamment
extérieurement présentable voilà ils
peuvent avoir des débordements
émotionnels peut avoir mais oui mais au
final c'est le produit fini c'est
important qui va provoquer que la
personne elle est elle est talentueuse
franchement tu es c'est très bien que tu
lis l'histoire et vraiment je vais te
dire moi on va même pas faire le débat
sur des PDA ou pas je m'en fous total
l'important c'est ce que tu nous as dit
ce soir et si tu as quelque chose à
ajouter pour noter les spectateurs et et
voilà et tout pour les autres les autres
médias qui qui qui peuvent peut-être
faire un peu plus pour ces artistes mais
vous voyez l'image que vous me montrez
derrière c'est un récital que j'ai fait
en faculté en faculté il y a des
étudiants et des étudiants qui se
suicident qui en peuvent plus qu'on en
reparle mal que les professeurs les
dédaignes qui sont pas dans un parcours
où ils ont un sens de l'apprentissage
classique alors je vais peut-être que je
veux je me rends ridicule mais au moins
quelques têtes pour rien que j'aurais
venu pour là parce que moi aussi vous
voyez s'il faut prendre l'image les
enfants de l'eau c'est une fille que
j'ai connu ça me fait énormément penser
à ça c'est c'est quelque chose il y a
des personnes qui disparaissent on en
parle jamais et qui sont en situation on
va jamais parler de ces personnes là et
je ne suis pas comment dire alors autant
même si je crois
il faut qu'il soit sauvé ces personnes
là parce que merci les garçons
[Applaudissements]
c'est extrêmement important de
représentativité la télévision qui est
représentativité dans la culture vous
voyez moi ma maman elle a 72 ans je sais
pas ce qu'elle se dit en gros en direct
sinon en train de se fier de vous non